und ich denke mir so da musste hinterher
okay leute ich hab heute wieder mal was
super tolles und besonderes für euch die
märkte in den letzten tagen ist alles
tolle besonders und zwar ich hab gestern
in leipzig umgebracht gestern abend und
da gab es ein zwei szenen die ich aber
so geil dass ich die umwelt mit euch
teilen wollte weil das einfach so cool
und hat mir so gut gefallen dass ich das
jetzt auf youtube hochladen
allerdings hatte ich da im hintergrund
leider copyright musik nämlich es
aproxima nate und das harley beide
lieder würden halt bedeuten wenn ich sie
drin lassen würde dass das video erstens
sich monetarisiert werden kann das aber
kein problem
scheiß drauf das größere problem ist
aber dass ich dann nicht in deutschland
zeigen davon die meisten zuschauer
kommen herr leider aus deutschland was
das problem und deswegen weil ich es so
machen ich werde es im nachhinein
größtenteils minuten ein paar stellen
werde ich frei lassen aber welchen ton
drin lassen nämlich da wo ich irgendwas
sagen oder sogar dann würde ich euch
viel spaß mit dem ersten live stream
ausschnitt best of what ever als gut und
bis 9
ich glaube dass liebe gott hat man das
ganze über folgendermaßen wir haben 64
sg gespielt ich zusammen mit tom beck
und zaki wollen wir dem team dann auf
der map tschernobyl und sind da oben auf
den kran gegangen so haben da ein
bisschen gechillt und laura und dann wie
gesagt habe schon gehört das thema kam
auf einmal die kopp und die jungs hat
die ganze zeit gefragt ja wie gegen das
wir geben das war ich keine ahnung hat
ich hatte noch nie ein jacob auch nur
versucht ich habe vier kopf worauf muss
man achten muss man achten hallo und
tommi eckart dann versuchen mich zu
verarschen beziehungsweise hat sogar
gesagt er soll mir nicht verraten wie es
geht
und dann ist die situation eskaliert das
wasser kam exakt nextcomic adiós
sodann haben wir dann tom beck zusammen
runter geschlagen es passt auf zack er
landet einfach den mlg spontan und ich
habe mir sogar das kann nicht sein das
kann nicht sein das kann ich sein hatte
man auch mein gesichtsausdruck
und dann kommt halt von unten einen
greift ihn an und ich denke mir so da
musste hinterher
jetzt kommt die stelle an der ich mein
leben bis zum gehtnichtmehr feiere
einfach vollkommen übertrieben ich
gedacht hätte ich nie gedacht ich das
hinbekomme ja und dann blieb auch lieber
blue ich war ja noch minutenlang mein
leben
dann entdecke ich einen anderen gegner
auf dem hinterher gibt ein paar hits
jein
läuft weiter ich verfolgt ihn dann
stellt sich heraus dass der einem
dreierteam ist ich habe leute ob dreier
team ja hier ist nitsches alter und die
jungs verfolgen nicht
ich renn hoch aufs häuser dach verfolgt
von denen und dann passiert noch mal was
ich hab grad ein hartes problem leute
kein problem
aber ich habe es einfach irgendwelche
hat einer solo das war die ganze
geschichte obst die tür ist offen das
war die ganze geschichte ich hoffe dass
wir euch gefallen für mich was er von
mega cool ist war gestern wirklich der
stream der mir bisher am meisten
gefallen hat von allen streams nicht
jemals gemacht habe lasse gerne darum
nach oben da wenn es euch gefallen hat
wir sind zur nächsten video wieder haut
rein macht's gut